welcome to this video coverage for
around thirteen of the candidates this
is the penultimate round so it's getting
to the very very decisive stages this is
about the game kyle aachen on to the
most important game of this round simply
because it is the only real opportunity
to to stop island from getting another
match with Magnus Carlsen at the moment
is leading before this game with a plus
free score three wins and no loss the
only play and the tournament who has not
suffered a loss thank the only player
who else has not suffered two losses all
other players have lost at least two
games um yeah it is playing coyoacán who
is on fifty percent which sounds like a
lot less than plus three it is it's one
and a half points but if ki can actually
would win this game he would move within
have a point of honored and would
actually gain the better tie break
because he had would have won this game
so it is not clear yet um but what is
clear if I not wins this game he's
absolutely qualified and wins the
tournament outright directly after this
round if he draws it's very very very
likely with the draw only Aronian could
stop him with two wins which given the
form that Aronian has displayed in this
tournament and in the last couple of
rounds does not really does not really
seem so lightly so a draw would be
excellent for this year win of course
even better let's see what happens kayak
and plays deform which is nowadays also
known as the entire Berlin same with
nida three and ce4 yeah he's normally an
e4 player but I guess it would have been
a safe bet that aren't would have chosen
this super solid response with the
Berlin defense so default played and we
got a Queens gambit with he six yeah a
lot that played the slaw
earlier in the tournament more than once
but this time we got esox the classical
way to play um kayaking no plates Knight
f3 this was his preparation played this
quickly it would have been very
interesting to see what island would
have played after Knight c3 um in the
world championship match against Magnus
Carlsen he had played c6 which allows
this gambit movie form and which is very
sharp a play and I really doubt that
honored would have allowed that so quite
interesting um but how to hard to tell
maybe would have gone Bishop e7 its own
it's just a guessing game or job it
didn't happen 9f three plates Knight f6
and now kayaking played the movie III
which has been played before in this
tournament by kramnik against uronian
Cromley got a very promising attacking
position and actually could have won the
game during time travel um yeah III is
not the most common move it looks a bit
a bit passive because it blocks in the
bishop but it has a very distinct
advantage show compared to other lines
it leads to play with all pieces on the
board in lights like you like the lusca
variation which wish she had played for
example in this decisive game against
Apollo in 2010 um there it is very
likely that you will get a very dry and
simplified position which after he three
is simply not happening we will get a
position with many pieces on the board
yeah Bishop e7 now plate and aronian had
played b6 and transposed to yeah kind of
a Queen's in the information on a device
that is going for Bishop e7 and castles
first
no bishop to be too yeah that's in
general White's idea is playing with the
queenside fianchetto and quite often can
try to start some initiative from the
Kings side later for example of black
now plays in a somewhat yeah let's say
passive men are not bd7 let's say c 6
i'm just showing the general idea then
white would gladly put the knight on d5
and maybe even continue with their for
this is very similar to the Kramnik
Aronian game and this is quite dangerous
for black actually so an odd was not
interested in doing any of those
somewhat passive setups he wants to free
the position quite quite immediately
placed c5 kayaking now captured yeah now
with with the night um yeah I guess that
he takes DM it's not terrible for black
but you don't really want to have an
isolated greenport position here which
is probably this type of position is
probably um only very slightly better
for white but it gives white some
concrete idea what to do namely
pressurizing the pawn and this was not
necessary at all so just taking with the
night is sufficient okay yeah kayaking
no for me at least slightly surprisingly
took on c5 but maybe there really is not
not so much else if you consider
something like Bishop d3 like will take
and you don't really have a good
recapture eat XD is just a very stupid
looking isolated queen power position
and there are even direct problems with
the move like night f for attacking g2
attacking be three so we probably need
to take weather with a piece and
what is simply not very well placed him
okay so he took it's probably right then
and Allah now didn't recapture he could
have played Bishop takes d5 but you
plate 97 trying to get the pawn with the
night which would be quite nice
obviously neither sir well placed on c5
so kayaking decided to drop the pawn on
c6 giving black at least and a weakness
IAM on c6 yeah so what has the better
structure is this better for white hmm
maybe slightly very slightly the
compensation that black hairs for the
weakened form structures the better
development he's got three pieces in
play already and castles in so let's say
four and white only has the two pieces
here developed and the king is still in
the middle so what black has tried to do
is to use his nicely developed forces
here with a five and here when they form
using his development to try to get rid
of the weaknesses and simplify the
position as much as possible yeah of
course there is a technical issue
already c6 is hanging and kayaking grab
the pawn which is probably the the right
decision if you play a a very slowish
move like this for example Blackham has
no problems at all he can take on b3 or
play Bishop a 6 if black gum without any
direct problem exchanges a pawn for be
porn it is just a very equal position c6
is somewhat weak but b3 is not much
better so it's probably a
around round equal yeah it took on c6
kayak ended and yeah I don't played the
move Queen a 5 which looks quite um yeah
quite normal activating the Queen it
covers that tag rook rook black however
had a pretty good alternative which
however is yeah easily pointed out by by
the computer but not at all a parent for
a human player this must look a5 quite
strange looking but it's it's not bad at
all it has a very concrete idea the
Queen on c6 it's not exactly well placed
if white now tries to grab this for
example this rook c5 and the Queen asst
is trapped unfortunately yeah I mean
okay what can go here but after Queen c7
it gets very very tricky as an ID b6
coming you won't avoid the Queen loss
here white cannot take on a 4 so
probably needs to retreat after which
black can continue with Bishop here and
possibly queen to a 8 and this is a very
substantial compensation already in some
cases the pawn can be regained really
quickly let's say like this check and
wait just a moment yeah and here on
black can for example play Queen to add
double attacking here and attacking only
form yeah black has a very good
development Queen a rook air-five was
even a bit more precisely Queen a five
after Queen a five white can take on a
four year and we get
get this position we are white at the
moment is even two points up but you can
quickly spot that black will get
something back the a pond here on a4a
sir is simply a simply God yup like has
lots of activity for for the poem and
the media problem is for white what
about this you for pond yeah you can try
to push it with you five but after 95
it's questionable if white has gained
anything it's um yeah I think black has
very good compensation you actually as
the e5 is just giving away a square on
d5 and not doing much the problem is you
cannot really protect you form
mechanically with some peace the best
move is Bishop b5 this is also what
kayaking played black now grabs only for
there is the move Bishop to c6 yeah
quite a problem so Anna took on a form
getting one of the pawns back and doing
so basically where the tempo as the
bishop is hanging and Bishop d7 yeah we
got got those traits in and whites the
last upon on the other hand what the
black hands he's got this pressure along
the a file and has some chances to get
the a porn back yeah this position is
probably some somewhere between slightly
better for white and equal it's it's
probably slightly better for what
because black must play very precisely
to get to the pawn back and in some
cases he doesn't really am achieve his
aim without conceding something we will
see what happens in the game it's a
after Luke see one okay for fairly
logical Uxie to brigade Luke see when we
see that white ass
substantial play against against c5 and
yeah it is the question what what black
should do now the problem is that you
cannot really am yeah move it away so
black basically has no choice in this
position he cannot move the night so he
took on a 2 which is of course not a
happy move certainly not but the only
move that was still available problem is
of course white can take here with the
rukon c5 after Bishop takes the bishop
cakes and rook c8 we get this position
completely by force so after move 26 we
have reached an end game already well
why it has got to Bishop and night
against rook so obviously this position
is better for what is the the only 12 to
have any sort of chance to win the game
but if it is really manageable is an
entirely entirely different question um
I think that this position is very very
very very tough to to win if if possible
at all the problem is that from Wright's
point of view the problem is that it's
four and four on the on the King side
and this these are notoriously difficult
to win when you don't get any kind of
pass porn and here the additional
problem is that blacks pawns are
absolutely ideally placed there is
absolutely no weakness in blacks
position and he can also alter the pawn
structure slightly still keeping a
position without any substantial
weaknesses this would be entirely
different if we would have
some porn weaknesses IAM let's say for
example just to illustrate my point if
both sides for example would miss the f
porn yeah just a argument's sake let's
imagine these are not on the board then
why it would immediately be a very
substantially better as he could try to
play a combined attack against the
weakness only six I know it's a dark
squared bishop this does not help but at
least I'm lacking f porn would give
black some weaknesses the e6 pawn and
also the pawns on g7 and h7r would be
somewhat more vulnerable in this case
there's absolutely no weakness and this
makes it very very tough to to get
anywhere yeah Alan place 95 directly
attacking here King III and f6 you have
six prepares them coming with e5 played
here just to get a bit more space and
control the center yeah it's um not so
easy to to analyze this type of position
the question is simply can white provoke
any sort of weakness that you can attack
with his pieces I am I have my doubts to
be honest um it's not easy to Stu to
tell what kind of weakness you should be
able to to create with this solid
structure we can continue for a bit and
see what happens now it's a slightly
changed on the Kings side but it's still
not apparent how Y term can get anywhere
basically it's only possible to make any
headway if you do any sort of porn push
like prepared
reform or prepare f4 without pushing any
of the pawns you won't make any progress
whatsoever it's it's simply a question
of activity of the pieces those two
pieces that black has left are active no
question the rook is a nuisance on the
second-ranked the night is also actively
placed always attacking on on e4 if we
look at this now from from whites point
of view yeah what what could he try
maybe maybe at some point you should try
a form just to to alter the structure a
bit but i'm not sure if it leads to to
nem any substantial progress not really
I mean black is probably just sitting
tight and won't won't do much 97 I don't
know to take with the night Pope could
be an idea not so sure about the best
setup or maybe black can also play rook
a phone attacking or knee form it's a
it's really tough to to analyze this
pasar con with concrete lines um let's
say let's say 97 just for for argument's
sake Knight f3 yeah yeah yeah maybe
maybe this is a bit a bit more testing
it's still not like a very easy way to
to to progress can even go back here to
see 5 I think it probably should have
tried something like that kayaking in
the game is some keeping the structure
maybe also considered that yeah okay you
can go F for later maybe you wanted to
do that with a bit more time on the
clock that's possible
some repetitions yeah here in this
position and when Drew k 1 he could have
taken on c1 but I don't think that this
is particularly helpful giving Y 2 nite
system is I think a bad idea because
nights in this structure are probably
the best pieces for y to have as they
are working on just one flying only the
King side and there may be a easier to
coordinate than the night and the bishop
so this makes sense to to move her look
to a one and now keeping the rogue
active yeah night possibly coming to see
form and now we've had to pass the time
control so both players got an
additional hour for 20 moves and
kayaking also trying hard to to make
headway he however we gotta a piece
trade operation it was probably an
unavoidable at the moment so that we
actually get rook against the two pieces
without nights on the board yet here we
have the same problem how is white I'm
ever going to make any progress yeah
probably with their form seems to be the
only way forward and maybe this is what
kayaking should have done earlier as as
mentioned on here Anand place the
important move g5 he's moving he's
blinking first so to say but he wants to
make sure that f4 is not not easily
possible yeah can white player for now
check this is a problem you cannot
do a form right away how to progress
then without the move yeah I did some
some brief analysis before I started
this video I didn't have so much time of
man's butt I'm looking a bit while I'm
while I'm doing the recording and are we
trying to get to get some ideas it's
very difficult it's really very
difficult question now is of course
should you take on g5 or should you let
black take um yeah you know probably you
should um you should take this is what
kayaking did I mean this has the the
benefit of giving white at least two
clear points to attack v5 and g5 the
question however is is this in any way
substantial does this lead to to win I
don't really I don't really know if you
maybe if he's if he just waits yeah well
black yeah black is not in any way
forced to take black can also do the
waiting game yeah maybe it's not really
measuring much and why it needs to take
on g5 anyway yeah okay this is what you
did and now we try to combine this his
pieces against the weaknesses yeah g4 to
fix this weakness um yeah what what else
is there besides besides g4 I can this
would be very nice but is this working
thus the the real problem go here yeah I
can I can play that move and it's not
easy to coordinate going here it's not
helping that much i also have roxy to
like this for example
and now maybe I'm starting a very
concrete count to play with the h-bomb
it's a gap that that's no real
improvement to the game you play g4 as i
mentioned to fix the weaknesses after
which are not replied h 4g for h1 yeah
so black has got the pestle on the H
file and it continues of course with
white trying to attack one of the pawns
twice and capturing it this is quite
simple the question is can wide attack
let's say 'if I've twice and take it
without any direct problem in term of
course this contingent for a very long
while it's a kayak in sir only chance
this game but it does not seem that why
it has any way forward there's also the
simple fact that f3 is also a weakness
that always can be a sport to to
counter-attack yeah here it looks like
at first sight ok this is this is nice
already I need to get the night improved
but how to do it no you play the King
back but can you actually do that for
example trying here here yeah the
question is is this really working
something like that don't forget the H
porn if Y term is doing something like
that check at the end days the h-bond
this of course is even worse black has a
very substantial counter play with this
with this pawn on h4 check yeah it's a
always tactical things happening here
maybe h3 is the reason why this is not
working like this and how do you stop h2
now well there's there's no way relief
the bishop is also tied to the night you
cannot really move any of the pieces so
we went to f1 and try it further the
other point of attack of course is g5 if
you would somehow managed to put a
bishop only three night on age three and
take it would be winning check but do
you actually manage to do that here
check you can get the Bishop to e3 at
some stage check can put a bit more on
the board it's a check lots of
repetitions without really being a
decisive here we get to this point let's
say plate King to g1 but let's say white
tries to to to attack here ok I'll go
here go here ok chance till the h-bond
very important resource yeah and what's
happening now it's a slight technical
problem already if white takes on age 3
i'm going to play root k 1 and the
question is if black can win yeah here
white is absolutely no chances to win
chan to g1 yeah can always counter take
on a three
and combine this with the h-bond
counterplay check yeah deserve this
actually happened with age three qinger
to f1 yeah if white takes it on age
three days rookie 2 and this is a very a
very problematic piece now you can go
here rookie 3 and now i'm white can can
try to defend themselves with 95 but
this is obviously not a winning tribe
plate king of 1 h 2 and now tied to h1
ki can really tried the utmost trying to
now get the pawn on edge too but it's a
pin but of course this is important if
if black ass is just ignoring all that
there's this one and what will pick up
this pawn and this is probably the win
but there is this pin on the first rank
cannot move king is pinned or the bishop
is pinned to the king yeah kingi to
plate and in fact in this position they
already agreed to a draw it's a it's
really nothing that that white can can
try here ok I can gave up at this point
and offer the draw yeah black is simply
too active you can just stay on the
first rank and there is no one no way
forward so I did in fact hold this game
hold this draw it was certainly wasn't a
very fun experience being in this end
game after 29 moves but sometimes in
this kind of situations where you where
you know that the draw is enough this
kind of let's say slide suffering in an
end game can be can be relatively a good
solution for you because you are can
very much focus on the task at hand and
you are not irritated by anything or
confused by an attack or whatever you
just know KN words
and as I need to keep this together and
it was I think manageable but very often
in this type of end games of you look at
this this is endgame you always get this
slight feeling and maybe this is also
why cards is such a magnificent opponent
that people actually have this this big
respect or this big fear if they play
him that they would lose its this type
of position yeah you always get the
feeling L at mango's play that he will
win this game for I don't know how he
does it but this type of endgame one
where you normally say okay oh okay why
does a bit better but no way that is
going to end and win but he's doing that
so often so are you very often you get
to get this feeling but it is a very
good for honor that he has actually hold
that dirty managed to hold this game not
for the the very important reason of
course that it basically secures the
tournament victory but also it shows him
that he can hold this kind of tough
tricky positions and in long games where
he made many inaccurate moves in earlier
games and especially in the world
championship match which proved am very
very costly so with this draw on an
autism almost almost is no not almost
I'm wrong here right the only person who
can catch him is Aronian with two wins
but he's got the better tie break so
with this draw i can actually without
spoiling anything say that Anand has has
qualified yes yes qualified for the
match ever thought was always think
about the other results and so on so he
has qualified with this draw to play
another match with mungus cards I want
to do any much comments on this fact I
will do that for the with for the final
for the final round video where sum up
the whole tournament a bit so just for
this game thanks for watching